Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Buongiorno a tutti.
Visto che Claudio ha scherzato:
“Sì, Matteo era prima”,
non sono parte correlata né in positivo
né in negativo, sganciatemi.
Lo dico perché era un cognome tranquillo,
poi, chiaramente, c’è chi mi chiede
gli 80 euro, le 500.
Sono, però, un padre di famiglia
con due figlie splendide
e una moglie insegnante.
I temi che tratteremo hanno importanza
per il futuro dei nostri figli
e per la società.
Non li tratterò
dal punto di vista politico,
ma li tratterò basandomi su dei fatti
e senza connotazioni ideologiche.
Volevo darvi delle informazioni al fine di
discuterne e di aprire una riflessione.
Sono riflessioni personali
che sto facendo da tempo
attorno a questo tema
e che volevo condividere.
Bene, computer e cervello:
come andrà a finire?
Ecco, facciamo per capire,
in base a dei dati oggettivi,
una brevissima storia dell’informatica.
Ho dieci minuti non partiamo dall'abaco,
partiamo un po’ più velocemente.
Siamo arrivati oggi a dei sistemi,
detti “learning system”
che fanno apprendimento automatico
dalle informazioni
che prendono da vari strumenti.
Siamo arrivati? No, non siamo arrivati.
Se prendete il cervello
di ciascuno di voi in questa stanza,
il vostro cervello ha
venti petaflop di potenza.
Cosa siano i petaflop è un tema
lungo da spiegare.
Vi dico solo che il più grande
supercomputer oggi in Italia,
sta a Bologna al Cineca,
è da 2,4 petaflop; il prossimo
che stiamo facendo in Eni,
4 petaflop.
Il vostro cervello ha cinque volte
più potenza di calcolo
del più grande supercomputer italiano
e consuma 20 watt, che è molto poco.
Quindi quando uscite con lo strudel,
non serve tutto questo zucchero
per alimentare il cervello.
Quindi ne basta poco.
Cosa fa un cervello umano?
Un cervello umano fa tre cose:
calcola, elabora dati e prende decisioni.
Poi, apprende dalle esperienze con i sensi
e parla il linguaggio naturale,
quindi comunica con un linguaggio,
per l'appunto, naturale.
Stanno avvenendo alcune cose nell'ambito
dell’intelligenza artificiale:
la prima cosa che sta avvenendo è
che le macchine riconoscono
sempre meglio le cose.
Una cosa che riconoscono
sempre meglio è le facce.
C'era un error rate alcuni anni fa
del 30%, si sbagliava il 30% delle volte.
Oggi la macchina sbaglia il 5/6%
delle volte la faccia che ha di fronte.
Le applicazioni sono infinite.
Con la Carnegie Mellon University
stiamo facendo applicazioni
per un non vedente
con la camera e dice:
“Sta arrivando Filippo ed è contento”.
pensate poi la sicurezza, voglio dire,
noi abbiamo numerose applicazioni,
in giro per il mondo,
di riconoscimento delle facce.
A proposito, la macchina riconosce
che è contento perché la macchina
sa riconoscere le emozioni.
Noi, per capire l'emozione di chi abbiamo
di fronte, mandiamo le emoticon.
Rifletteremo.
Secondo tema: le macchine hanno sempre
più dati per allenarsi.
C'è un bel film, si chiama “Her”,
qualcuno di voi l’avrà visto.
Lui si innamora di lei.
Lei è un computer.
Ha la voce di Scarlett Johansson,
così suadente da vincere il premio Oscar
senza nemmeno averla mai vista nel film.
Lui domanda a lei: “Ma cosa pensi?”
e lei dice: “Penso a te”.
Evvai, questo tutto gongolante:
“Cos'altro?”
“Sto leggendo 8000 libri
e sto parlando con altre 150 persone.“
Come calcolo l’uomo è molto meglio della
macchina, come memoria non c'è verso.
Io non mi ricordo neanche il cellulare,
di mia moglie sì,
ma di mia figlia non a memoria.
La memoria dell’uomo non ha paragone
con quella delle macchine.
La potenza di calcolo sta aumentando a
dismisura: quello che batteva
il campione del mondo di scacchi,
alcuni anni fa, si chiamava Deep Blue,
pesava 1,4 tonnellate.
Oggi, quel telefonino che avete in tasca,
un decimo del vostro telefonino,
è più potente di quella macchina lì.
Tutta la potenza di calcolo
che ha portato l'uomo sulla Luna nel ‘69
oggi è contenuta in una frazione
microscopica della potenza di calcolo
del vostro smartphone, più o meno smart.
Sull'intelligenza artificiale
stanno avvenendo oggi
una serie di investimenti massicci.
Un sacco di soldi stanno andando a finire
in quest'ambito per svariate ragioni.
Questa è la teoria,
in pratica se volete provare a casa,
c'è Gloogle, cercate personality insight.
Questo lo abbiamo fatto noi in IBM
ma ne trovate varie.
Potete metterci dentro i dati di testo
di una pagina scritta da Gandhi.
Io ci ho messo una pagina
scritta da Gandhi,
una pagina scritta da Hitler
e una pagina scritta dal mio capo
e lui fa l'analisi psicologica
della controparte.
Il mio capo era più vicino a Gandhi
che a Hitler, certi giorni, altri giorni..
Un'altra cosa che sta avvenendo in rete è:
voi andate e navigate felici,
perfetto, bene, quando avete notato
che succedono delle cose strane
di fianco alla vostra navigazione.
Stesso identico orario, io e un mio amico.
Lui stava ristrutturando
un trullo in Puglia, quello in alto,
e io stavo cercando
una nuova macchina in leasing,
dal quale stavo scegliendo la macchina.
Guarda caso, il sito web a lui suggeriva,
attorno all'informazione
che aveva cercato, quella di Tsipras,
in quel momento informazioni immobiliari.
A me suggeriva oggetti delle macchine.
Che cosa cosa avviene dietro le quinte?
Si chiama, senza entrare nella tecnologia,
“cognitive tagging”
e, fisicamente, ci piaccia o no,
oggi stanno avvenendo dentro,
quando navigate,
tutta una serie di fenomeni di tagging.
La macchina sta cominciando a capire
il significato di quello che cercate,
il significato delle parole.
Se parliamo il linguaggio naturale
cominciamo a entrare in questo mondo.
Sta avvenendo in questo momento
un ulteriore passo.
La macchina sta acquisendo
senso e sensibilità, questo è importante.
Innanzitutto, la parola “senso”
ha infiniti sensi.
Dal punto di vista anatomico,
se prendiamo la Treccani,
i cinque sensi, senso di tipo anatomico,
oppure c'è un significato filosofico:
il senso della vita.
Un significato linguistico:
il senso delle parole.
Bene, le macchine stanno cominciando
ad acquisire sensi con i sensori,
essendo più pieno di sensori
attorno a noi.
Che cosa avviene all'interno del sistema?
Avviene che la macchina
interpreta i dati per voi,
dà un senso ai dati di tipo filosofico,
adesso assolutamente
filosofico non profondo,
ma dà un senso ai dati avuti
dai sensori per vostro conto.
La macchina che invece dà
un senso linguistico ai dati
è quello che abbiamo visto prima:
contact tagging
e strumenti del tipo precedente.
Lo facciamo.
Lo si può fare per delle vigne,
lo si può fare per per la medicina,
lo si può fare
per la gestione del traffico.
Queste macchine, quindi,
stanno acquisendo sensibilità.
E allora che resta all'uomo?
L’uomo è ancora in vantaggio
sulla macchina per una cosa importante,
che è quella del senso comune.
Il buon senso, come si chiamava una volta.
Guardate la foto bassa alla vostra destra,
è una foto nota
in letteratura scientifica:
si chiama: “Anne e la babysitter”.
Vedete, c’è la babysitter
e un’altra persona.
Chiunque di voi mi direbbe
che Anne è la bambina
e la babysitter è quella signora grande,
corretto?
Qualcuno ha un’idea diversa?
Questo perché il buonsenso,
ma la logica di una macchina
non mi porta a quello.
La persona piccola potrebbe essere
una signora piccola che fa da babysitter
ad una ragazzotta grossa di quindici anni,
e chi ha detto che la babysitter
deve essere di età superiore
all’età della babysittata?
Il buon senso si, ma la pratica no.
Altro esempio di uomo
in vantaggio sulla macchina:
la macchina va su motori statistici,
su considerazioni di statistica,
su medie, gaussiane, normale.
C'è un classico esempio di Nicholas Taleb,
che ha scritto un bel libro,
“Il cigno nero”:
se voi foste un contadino
e un maiale avesse capacità statistiche.
Bene, il maiale statistico ogni giorno
riceve tre chili di roba da un contadino,
quindi, in media tre, 3,1-2,9 chili.
In media il contadino è una brava persona.
In pratica, a Natale,
il contadino lo ammazza, corretto?
Statisticamente va bene.
Ecco, il buon senso non è una roba on-off,
il buon senso o c'è o non c'è.
Quindi, se il contadino è un disgraziato
è disgraziato sempre, non statisticamente.
Ho fatto due esempi stupidi
però per darvi un’idea
del perchè l’uomo è in vantaggio
sulle macchine nel buonsenso.
Questa è una pubblicità
della IBM negli anni ‘50.
Vendendo quei computer, dicevamo:
“Se ti accatti una di quelle
macchinozze nere giù in basso,
150 extra engineer o regoli calcolatori
non ti servono”.
Sappiamo poi come è andata a finire:
i 150 extra engineer l’azienda
li ha assunti per metterli
attorno alle macchinozze nere.
Però, nei secoli scorsi,
è successo che l’uomo è passato
dall'umanesimo alle competenze.
Rivoluzione industriale, impararava
a fare un lavoro, una competenza.
E poi negli anni 1940/50,
dopo la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
ancora più lavoro-capacità,
quindi molto più specifico:
giro il regolo, faccio la cosa...
Le macchine hanno cominciato,
a loro volta, facendo cose
assolutamente insensate
sin dall'inizio: paghe/stipendi.
Quindi le macchine sono partite
dalla capacità.
Poi, però, le macchine sono risalite,
hanno fatto dei software
che vanno a fare delle competenze,
quindi fanno gestione degli ERP,
gestione del magazzino.
Oggi le macchine stanno acquisendo senso.
Cosa sta avvenendo al contempo all'uomo?
L'uomo, in teoria, è in vantaggio
sulle macchine nel buon senso,
come abbiamo detto prima.
Certo però in teoria
tra la teoria e la pratica
non c’è differenza, in pratica c’è.
Diceva un filosofo:
“In teoria tra la teoria e la pratica
non c’è differenza, in pratica c'è”.
In pratica stiamo perdendo, noi umani,
molto spesso il buon senso,
qualche volta scimmiottando le macchine,
che è una provocazione!
È un problema che vedo.
Se il nostro punto di forza
è il buon senso
e noi ci mettiamo a scimmiottare
delle macchine,
che il buon senso non ce l’hanno,
vedo un problema.
Che cosa dobbiamo fare quindi?
Dobbiamo fare una cosa molto semplice:
avere il coraggio di osare.
La macchina non ha coraggio
perché non ha coscienza:
il problema del coraggio
la macchina non se lo pone.
Avere il coraggio di osare
è fare cose di buonsenso.
Non è così difficile,
siamo disegnati per quello,
basta che il cervello
vada dove lo porta il cuore.
Grazie per l'attenzione.
[Applausi]